okay so earlier this week I interviewed
TM Garrett who is a former white
supremacist was in the German version of
the KKK who told us about how he was
radicalized and eventually how he became
D radicalized as well as his involvement
and the appeal of being part of a lot of
the groups that he was a part of dating
all the way back to age 15 growing up in
Germany today for the classic interview
we'll go back to my interview with Scott
Shepard who is also a former white
nationalist white supremacist KKK guy
but from here in the United States he
was a former Grand Dragon of the KKK in
Tennessee he now is an anti racism
campaigner a totally different take on
how he got into and out of extremism but
I think you'll notice some similar
themes the sense of wanting community
the triggers for saying you know the
doubts I've been having about these
movements have now surpassed the level
at which I can sort of comfortably or
semi comfortably continue ignoring them
and continue doing what I'm doing
horrible things by the way so let's get
to my interview from March of 2016 with
former KKK Grand Dragon Scott Shepard
it's great to be joined again by Scott
Shepard a former Grand Dragon of the KKK
in Tennessee now a anti racism
campaigner he has turned his back on the
KKK and this is Scott's second
appearance on the program Scott you know
what I always wonder Grand Dragon Grand
Wizard like what are these ranks it
sounds like a tabletop board game to me
well basically aims at they views you
know force Grand Dragon would be
compatible with like a governor of the
state say well it's a state took the
seat and you of course you got the Grand
Wizard that'd be compatible to compared
to the president President of the United
States it's just a you know a list of of
terms that you know given the officers
and stuff from the ranks on down to go
by chain of command so wizards are
higher than dragons and
keh keh keh hi the grand wizard or
sometimes called grand wizard imperial
wizard is a national director is the top
level he's just like the president all
right I mean I just like the president
but sure you know that's the you know
the rank right it's not exactly like
being president of the United States but
maybe in their mind it sort of is right
so you know we've seen with the Donald
Trump campaign so many different white
separatist and white supremacist groups
have pointed out for a variety of
reasons that Donald Trump is inspiring
them to vote and to get out and try to
support Trump's candidacy we've seen
David Duke say that Donald Trump is the
guy what what do you see is someone who
was in the KKK at one point as what is
the the appealing element of Trump's
rhetoric to these individuals why do
they like him well basically I think his
say you know basically when I was in
Texas from Memphis with Darrell Davis
who who you know you know familiar with
we uh we were sitting down and talking
of course Donald Trump is hitting on all
these issues and of course I can't say
Donald Trump's a racist per se right or
not but he's using he's using the turn
of these turns issues and stuff that the
KKK and all white supremacy groups have
hit on for years and years and years and
I'll say this the wedding Donald Trump
it would be someone else and then forces
people remember Patrick Buchanan yeah it
was a big presidential campaign that was
supported by the white supremacist
movement
yeah Buchanan's the last guy that was
sort of able to coalesce these elements
of the the extreme right into something
that that was a group of people
supporting a sort of alternative type of
candidate but I don't think Buchanan
came close to sort of being the catalyst
that Donald Trump is for getting the
support I mean we talked about storm
front the storm front website it had to
upgrade its servers in part to deal with
the increased web traffic they're
getting because of Trump's candidacy
we've seen a resurgence from the daily
stormer which recently sent all sorts of
anti-semitic
faxes to universities around the country
is your sense that Donald Trump's views
on immigration from Latin American
countries have hit a nerve is it his
proposed ban on Muslim travel I mean
what specifically do you think it is
specifically I think it has do with
atmosphere that we in today you know of
course when Patrick Buchanan grand there
wasn't a whole lot of this of the
terrorism going on then that's going on
now and I think this atmosphere of the
you know entire nation in world was you
know whatever it's just kind of people
are more angry and they're picking up on
these issues a lot more and of course
Donald Trump's campaign and David Duke
campaign if they ran in the past boot
run parallel these are the issues that
the Klan white supremacist groups and
stuff picked up to you know try to
legitimize their self to make them look
more into the mainstream of politics and
they use these different candidates like
that to know for self gain you know they
you know that's some of their programs
you know the he illegal immigration and
things like that but that's where they
jump on bandwagons of these mainstream
politicians that are getting on these
same issues and I think it has to do
with anger and and and fear you
mentioned something earlier that I want
to go back to because I've been talking
about it also you said you can't really
say whether Donald Trump is a racist and
and I've been saying for a while
that I don't know that Donald Trump even
really believes half of what he's saying
I don't think he expected to get nearly
as far as he did in this presidential
campaign one really interesting thing is
that Donald Trump's daughter has
converted to Judaism her husband is
Jewish Donald Trump's grandkids many of
them are Jewish you would think that
this would be a huge turnoff to groups
like the KKK and other white separatist
and white white supremacist groups why
do they seem to still support Trump and
in spite of the fact that so much of his
own family is Jewish well I believe this
because just like I said Trump hitting
on all these issues that the plan and
white supremacist groups have used you
know they it wouldn't matter like I said
it wouldn't matter if it was Donald
Trump for anyone else I know the Jewish
issues would you know is out there and
you would yes you would think that they
gonna it would like to distance itself
from Trump because of that but again
they're latching only someone that's in
the mainstream public right there and
Donald Trump is and they're just you
know they're opportunities you know
they'll overlook these issues by self
gain you know they don't they don't care
about Donald Trump Jewish connections or
anti Jewish connections they're just
looking for a opportunity to jump on the
bandwagon to make yourself look more
legitimate hey Scott when you were in
the KKK were there ever any candid
conversations with the other you know be
it dragons or wizards or underlings or
whoever whoever it was at the time where
you guys kind of candidly said yep I
don't actually really think that the
Jews are bad people or black people or
bad people or whatever but you sort of
said this is the the sort of the talking
points that we're using and subscribing
to where they're candid conversations of
doubt or was it know if you're in this
group
you'd better express support a hundred
percent of the time well pretty much you
have to express you know Express at home
percent of the time you know at the time
also you know years ago I didn't really
get into the anti Jewish movement
because it it wasn't an issue with me
that you know about Jewish people I've
raised up with Jewish people and always
had a good relationship some good
friendships and still friends with today
because we grew up together but you know
I was a candy didn't in Tennessee for
governor and state representative and we
did you know I know this is what the
people do I did the same thing I jumped
right on those issues that Donald Trump
is using another vein stream candidates
it's just Donald Trump it's coming out
and saying saying boldly and out loud
what's being said behind closed doors
and I don't care if the Republican Party
wants to act like they're gonna you know
disavow Donald Trump or whatsoever
you know he is saying what's being said
mr. smoke-filled back rooms did you ever
get the sense when you were in the KKK
that the that there's this common
refrain you often hear from groups like
the KKK it's not so much that we're
against other races but we want to
defend and support the white race right
it's a sort of white pride movement as
opposed to an anti non-white when we
hear that talking point do people in the
KKK believe that or do they understand
that it's just sort of a way to make the
movement more palatable from a PR
perspective not very effective but is
that sort of understood to be nonsense
or do people really believe that that
the KKK is an anti other races it's just
Pro white well I think you've pretty
much hit the nail on the head it's it
you know it's an image thing and they
use that second you know example of the
cheese you know they say they're not
anti black or whatever and then for say
you know they're just saying if probe
white want equal rights to whites and
they play black should have equal rights
also but behind closed doors they're
using the n-word and and making jokes
you know it's people of color and
different religions so so yeah it's a
smoke screen there's a smoke screen they
they really are but you know and they do
believe in separation of the races and
the right to you know the cept you know
determination but they against black
people totally I mean they just what's
inside and backgrounds not upfront
there's uh I don't know if you've seen
the TV series sons of anarchy but there
is a sort of storyline in that where the
the main biker gang turns out that they
have someone in their ranks who is part
black right and if it were to be found
out that would be really bad for this
half black guy do you have any stories
or recollections from when you were in
the KKK of sort of either suspicions or
it comes
light that someone who is in the group
actually is is partly non-white well yes
you know and I'll the most most
important most important example I can
give you some I self you know they say
that the KKK is white supremacist group
believe in a pure Rayz totally 100%
white blood you know no mixing of
whatsoever technically I wasn't even
supposed to be a member of Klan or
allowed to be a member to clan because I
got native Vivian in me I'm not you're
part of American and you knew that all
along oh I knew it all along right and
they just you know I just never I just I
guess I never gave it any thought but
you know now I can but I think there's a
lot of those situations like that now
I'm not the only one ya know is I'm
definitely not pure white and you know
who knows did the DNA no telling what
might pop up in me but you know they
don't give you a DNA test to join the
clan of white supremacist groups right
yeah maybe that'll be the next step in
the application process who knows
they're gonna have to tighten that up a
little bit if you can't have dragons and
wizards who aren't completely white
that's for sure Scott Shepherd former
Grand Dragon of the KKK in Tennessee
Scott it's always so great to talk to
you and tomorrow we'll be having Darrell
Davis on a friend of Scott's who has
produced an incredible documentary film
and and thank you so much Scott for
putting us in touch with him well I
appreciate it yeah I think you'll really
enjoy talking to Darryl and please tell
him hello for me I'll be talking with
him and I really really enjoyed being
able to be a part of that documentary
documentaries myself you really meant a
lot and I think it needs to be shown
completely across the country and you
know after all these films that's
because it it really strikes a nerve and
it's a unique way that Darrell's
approaching these issues and trying and
trying to tear down barriers of racism